e la tt ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj siamo su un altro
episodio di api wells
io l'ho dimenticato ragazzi che
dall'ultima volta che ho registrato
fallimenti freddy's che ho ancora con la
maglietta li devo ricordarmi di metterla
nell'armadio di chiudere l'armadio a
chiave in qualche modo perché cioè ogni
tanto mi sveglio e ciò con la maglietta
attaccato alla sedia e c'è questo
potrebbe essere un problema triggers a
un primo livello di oggi ragazzino mi
riguarda si gioca a questo gioco visto
che non ci ho mai giocato anzi di so che
non ci gioco spesso italia
in teoria sì dove si dovrebbe muovere
sto tizio fatica la porta per entrare
aiuta quindi non del non devo muovermi
ma mi muovo cliccando fantastic dead to
sleep un gioco pieno di energia sembri
persa hai bisogno di un aiuto non era a
posto grazie faceva posso andare avanti
non posso fare un cazzo e sto livello di
merda non posso andare avanti un po
sterile ho mica quanto ci hai messo per
usate gambe zio anch'io la mattina sono
lento far leggo però non così try out di
un back home juve con pizza vabbè sempre
meglio della pizza l'ananas efficace se
vuoi io ho bisogno che tu uccida
qualcuno programmata a caso entro in una
[ __ ] pizzeria uno mi avvicina anzi lo
avvicino io l'ho questo si gira e mi
dice ho bisogno che tu ci da qualcuno
per me va bene
ecco quando è da quando donald trump è
salito al potere che che succedono
queste cose prima non era così lui
indossa un cappello da baseball
va bene e sta fuori dalle crepe mart io
volevo comunque una pizza niente sono
entrato in una pizzeria per prendono una
pizza non la posso prendere va bene
autonation la madonna ebay strillava
mica volte figo o soltanto questa
macchina al momento si interessa solo
5.000 dollari sta una lamborghini ma
come ci combinato alla moda pene
detenuto dopo dai promesso ma cosa fai
non averli non lamborghini sconto mica
tarek awad ammazzo 1 e torno che mi
danno i soldi grossi e propri compro la
macchina grossa che retto in marta ecco
perfetto ciao zio devo ucciderti come
ammazza una persona
prenda pugni devo uccidere una persona
adatta e mi qualcosa per uccidere cioè
ed elemento che faccia momento scocca
cola e gliela faccio bene senti zio
potresti morire centimenti che ho
bisogno di lamborghini niente orano la
gente neanche ti fa i favori basilari un
cazzo lonegan qua e vendono le armi mi
chiamavo vi sono un deficiente frate ho
bisogno di una sega di una motosega lì
come che sta lì adesso sono ricco la
posso comprare vai perfetto dove già una
merda loro attento dove pisti vado a
fare il gangster adesso sono ritornato
borgaro e a mahler padre ma dal padre
come si spara
ho scoperto come si spari e un tutorial
tuo in realtà però grazie ho preso un
qualcosa che devo dare a quel tizio che
mi dà i soldi grossi all'astra ucciso il
tizio o ucciso dammi i soldi o ucciso sì
adesso consegno la pizza bologna non
sparano anche più fucile perfetto non
posso anche vi sparati in faccia che
storia dammi i soldi che l'ha ucciso
niente ora che c'è verso allora andate
tutti a cagare deficienti
lasciamo perdere che mi sono cagato il
cazzo visto arrivare nuova che ci gioco
profilo facciamo steel daimon premesso
che sarà sicuramente fattibile eco
esatto era troppo bello giocare per non
sono mai in durato così tanto senza
morire su happy with che linea livello
non si moriva grazie al cazzo teoria
l'ho preso però comunque in teoria
perfetto perfetto va bene così allora e
ho provato a cercare trump per vedere
che cosa trovo ma questo è un livello su
donald etra insomma più un impossible
fatto figo a è il muro ma costa bene
abbiamo risolto il problema dei
messicani è così che superano la
barriera voglio render wow che si suol
dire perché wow spiegami qual è il
problema
ovviamente io magari se ecco
preferiresti non mangiare più carne o
mangiare carne per il resto della tua
vita non mangiare più carne
assolutamente no non è né è che
sorvegliano è però è mark a [ __ ]
allora anche letto probabilmente però
era quella giusta perché ho letto
android quindi va bene preferiresti
essere riconosciuto come un razzista o
come un sessista donald trump non sapevo
cosa cazzo scegliere allora è entrambe
le cose ha scelto io spendo no vabbè
ormai non so se non anche più scegliendo
vado a caso le vele sea ray dieci
fratelli e 10 sorelle vegas
kat vabbè che poi non va beh non è detto
scandalizzato lo possa aprirsi
iscriverti al mio canale youtube fare la
dub frate andiamo con la dub fallo anche
tu con le gambe che è perfetto
bellissimo non lo sa che che fa la dub e
comunque non solo l'avete fatto a me tom
sua posizione harpoon gunshot
ok ma io sono più briaco di lui non
suscitano anche a colpirlo perfetto è
una bella sta posizione zio
va bene impossible 100 ml g fammi vedere
un po di snoop dogg zio che fanno sti
livelli qua che sono un botto ma non
sono impossible gli spacciano per
impossible ma non è un imposti col
parquet sono vivo sono vivo secondo me
questa cosa non gli fa neanche troppo
male credo non lo porto dietro fino al
traguardo allungati non ci credo frate
mi prende per il culo non mi prende il
ricovero effettivamente mi ha già preso
per il culo prova
perseverare ragazzi se la vita vi infila
un arpione nel culo non demordete zero
gravity rocket che perdemmo steve nei
meandri di happy with ma sta roba qua
c'è un modo per frenare ce l'avrà
sicuramente però non lo sapeva usare
quindi va bene porto il flip video ma
perché continuano a fare il botto il
fleet ma che problemi ci hanno perché
adesso va da un sacco sta roba del botto
il flip non non si è visto se però si è
girata con i va bene oltre online ball
trova lamentano il colore mai ho già
vinto michiara gara ma gli bolt roma ma
c'è qualcuno ma in come me ne son
cristiano che fa un boltro che sia
difficile non è impossibile fare un
altro impossibile ce l'avete capito kit
the ball faccia
ecco questo è molto diverso ma va bene
perfetto dove la mia vittoria
dov'è la [ __ ] avevate promesso la [ __ ]
dove non equa la figlia dodo spara ok
perfetto
non era così difficile niente boltro
sono tutti una cagata lo pensavo di
essere bravo in realtà fanno tutti
schifo tra i tuoi escape 1 ecco come non
è possibile come t
[Musica]
non riesco a captare la più difficile e
piffer ce l'ho fatta cosa cazzo stai
facendo io che non devi cacciarmi york
ma la malavita estate non ci credo se
non mi volle in 33 secondi ti ammazzo
anzi sei già molti amanti di vivo e tiri
ammazzo c'è un problema di fondo
qualcosa devo fare spiegatemi ecco vai
vinci bici vinci per me vittoria
schiacciante per farvi gvb 33 paula con
le tette
allora attento che youtube melo censura
e attenzione potrebbe un si sa mai ha
censurato per molto meno youtube
bene rock sword sorcery neanche leggere
porca [ __ ] che problemi con bravo da
perfetto non è fallo non è fallo e dei
gol e soprattutto i gol come si fa ok
perfetto come il fanta premio ho segnato
col casco col casco ho segnato col
portiere va bene in qualche modo
riuscirò a buttarla dentro
niente o amiche impossibile ma a fratte
veramente non riesco a buttarla dentro
ma merda ma aveva buttato dentro si no
non ci credo che c'è ronaldinho trave io
non ci posso credere ragazzi continua a
prendere la traversa dai porca [ __ ]
cos'è ma cosa stai fa cosa un palleggio
allora di cui non di quello modugno roja
di testa conti ma pararla o va bene
conosce agli spasmi eletta entra a borca
vip non ce la faremo mai
costo di toglierlo centrarlo sta
entrando questo e gol super valido voi
non capite il gioco del calcio io
capisco schiva questa nucleare non me lo
faccio difendere due volte zio ha
proprio sto andando in mezzo alla merda
va bene mi dovrà cadere addosso cosa
succede spiegatemi un attimo queste non
sono nucleari questi sono compiti di
matematica andati male anzi forse ancora
non sa ancora bene c'è nel senso i miei
erano peggiori da allora che soli spero
che vi do di oggi vi sia piaciuto dove
la maglia di fermate freddi se lì che mi
fissa tanto non toglierò mai però va
bene così
però il video sia piaciuto ragazzi come
senso ha bisogno di un momento è un mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook come
descrizione dove si siete vi ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazzi